Welcome to your Unreal training for stage operations, tool
execution, and optimization.
My name is Sean Spitzer, your senior instructor
at Epic Games.
And today, we're going to be talking about ICV effects
and tool operations and optimization
overall on your scene on the stage.
This is a bit of a review of our other courses,
but we're going to go and look at a few things to keep
in mind when you're on the stage.
We're not going to go through all of these,
since we've talked about plenty of them
within our courses, our live class,
what we're going to focus mainly on
is looking at our performance and how best
to get Unreal to do the things that we need.
And in 5.1, Lumen makes that much easier.
And the Lumen in 5.1 allows us to update our lighting
on the fly.
And we'll do a bit of a review
on some of those aspects and things
that you can use to your advantage.
I'll add a few more things in here that not necessarily
part of the class, but they will point out
the light updates that you can get going
and the different types of lighting scenarios
using LevelSnapshot.
I'll squeeze those in just a little bit
towards the middle of this course.
All right, so let's go ahead and go to Switchboard here
and we're going to take a look at a few things
also in Unreal.
So you'll see in Switchboard, if I go to my settings,
which I have up right now, I can actually run some traces
and tell what's going on with Unreal
by running CBAR commands as soon as Switchboard
and us launching to the wall starts to hit.
Now we can run a trace GPU if we need to.
You can also run, if I minimize things just for a second,
I'm going to close settings here
and I'm going to minimize Switchboard for a bit
and also Unreal.
You'll notice that we also can run Unreal Insights
as an EXE on your desktop.
Now, if you do run into problems with this
and if for some reason it's not quite hitting
or connecting, you may run into situations
where Unreal will require you to reinstall it
if Unreal Insights is fighting you a bit,
but you do can run Unreal Insights right within the engine.
It's not always the most ideal to do so
because you are running things in the background
as it's looking at your system and your setup,
but that option is there if you run into it.
So again, review, you can run Unreal Insights
through your Switchboard when you initially launch,
as you saw through our settings,
we can actually get those commands going
through our CVARS,
or you can run it through the EXE on the desktop,
or you can also run it live within your scene itself
by going to Tools and Unreal Insights.
And we talked about how to read that
in our previous courses from before.
So what we're going to do now
is take a look at our scene as a whole,
and we're going to jump ahead a few slides
and we're going to review some of the terminology
that we talked about when it came to draw calls.
Now, draw calls, when you're looking at them,
are two things specifically,
is your geometry is going to be a draw call,
and your materials are going to be a draw call.
These are very important to consider.
So you have to determine
where you're merging your geometry,
and also if you're going to be using Nanite
in Virtual Texturing.
This is very important to consider
because activating Nanite in Virtual Texturing
works really well and gives you
some really great scenes with Lumen.
Now, if we decided to use Nanite outside of Lumen,
those bakes will take a while.
And if I do that,
I'll have to make sure that I use GPU light mass
to be able to bake things quicker on stage.
This, again, is dependent upon your scene
and how complex it is overall,
and you have to consider those situations.
All right, in our previous class,
we talked about your draw calls
and your thread, your CPU, what's going on.
We also talked about what those determining factors are
when it comes to looking and examining your scenes,
and also what's being drawn by your camera.
And in our case, our camera is linked into our NDC,
so whatever's being drawn in our scene
is luckily not being drawn all at one time,
but according to what my camera's looking at,
which is fantastic that Unreal works that way,
and is to our advantage.
And we have the GPU visualizer that we can also use.
Now, I know a few people working in ICVFX
will sometimes use this quite quickly
because it gives you a quick snapshot of what's going on,
but they're not always dependent upon it.
They'll actually go to session front end,
or they all will also go to Unreal Insights.
Now, again, to get to the EXEs for some of those,
you'll see Unreal Insights is found within my Epic Games,
Unreal 5.1 engine binaries,
and Windows 64.
You'll find this right here,
but you'll also find session front end in here also,
if you wanted to be able to use that one as an EXE.
So now, let's go ahead in our scene
and take a look again at our GPU visualizer.
Now, your GPU visualizer, again,
is a very lightweight way to look at your scene overall,
and what's going on,
and you'll be able to activate that
through your output log here,
and in my output log,
which is just the same as if you hit tilde,
but I like this because it tells you what's going on.
You can also do a question mark at the end of your CVAR
if you're not sure what that CVAR does
and you want a quick breakdown of it.
Then we'll do profile GPU.
Now, the profile GPU, as a reminder,
takes a snapshot of that scene,
so you might want to bookmark areas,
and it allows you to be able to actually look at this
and see where in your milliseconds
you may be getting hit in your scene.
This one I've used for a while,
but I don't use it all the time.
A lot of times, I like to use session front end,
and I want to point out some of the changes
that do happen with session front end
because this has changed interface-wise just a bit.
As I open up session front end,
you'll notice, again, like I said,
you can run this through an EXE outside of Unreal.
I want to make sure that I have selected
the session that I want to analyze.
Now, to be able to profile that,
we want to make sure that we're selecting this one.
Let me open this up.
You can also load a profile that you already have.
Now, I don't have one in this particular session,
but we want to be able to activate a new one.
You'll see here that under console
is tracking some of the things
that are going on in our scene,
and you'll also see our Aja is at work
in balancing things out.
Now, I want to make that point
that our Aja is making sure that our frame rate
is set to a 30 frames per second,
but you can see the chug in what happens
with Unreal when you have a lot on your scene,
a lot of draw calls,
and then a lot of material's giving you trouble.
Maybe fog is giving you trouble, whatever it is.
You'll notice your camera lag is going to occur,
and we're going to be playing with that a little bit.
So here's our scene here that we have set up,
and you'll notice we also can actually
load things within groups.
So when loading your sessions,
you really want to make sure this is selected,
but I do want to point out in the automation part,
you can actually run tests.
If I started the test, it'll ask me to save,
and then I can run that session.
Now, we're not going to get into the test just yet,
but let's go to the profile here for a second.
We used to have icons in 5.0.
Now we just have text to be able to click on,
and I can actually grab my data capture,
and it's now capturing data for my scene,
and then I can click on data capture again.
It'll ask me,
would you like to transfer the captured stats?
Yes, please, it's going to keep it,
and it's going to give me a link,
and then now I can load that file.
Are you sure you want to load the session?
Automate results, data will be lost, we'll say yes,
because it was automating tests in the background,
or I can force it like I just did,
or I had it give me the data
from where I'm at right here.
Now, when you do run this,
I do recommend you move your camera around in your scene.
We didn't do this for this particular data capture,
but it allows me to go in here
and to be able to see where my issues might be.
Now, you can also search things accordingly,
so say, hey, maybe I think fog's giving me trouble,
so I can go and look at my fog up close,
double-click on it, and see if I'm getting hit anywhere,
and it looks like our fog is relatively not too bad
in this particular instance, so we're doing okay.
And again, our aja is keeping things locked down,
but you can analyze things,
and again, you really want to try to do this
before you get on the wall,
but there will be times where you're in that scenario
where you need to look at what's going on on the wall.
And I'm gonna show you, again,
a little bit of review with Level Snapshots,
how we can change our lighting,
but I'm gonna really focus on
what that lighting optimization means for your scene.
All right, so I'm gonna go and close this.
So we're in Lumen right now in our environment.
We've now checked out our NDC as well.
We want to make sure that our beach scene
is also checked out,
so I'm gonna go ahead and check this out for our scene.
Really important, because we're making changes here,
and we want those changes to be recorded.
Now you'll notice in our environment,
if Kevin will go over and switch to the camera on stage
and move the camera around,
we may get a little bit of lag,
but overall, it's actually not too bad.
And this is using water in our environment,
and water is probably one of the heaviest things
you can mess with.
Now, if we wanted to, we can push this water system back,
and we can also lower the complexity of our terrain.
Virtual texturing is gonna be very important
in this particular scenario, if it starts to lag too,
so we can switch that.
So let's go and talk about a review of virtual texturing
and using Nanite, as well as looking at Lumen up close.
So let's go back into the engine
and see where we can actually make things a bit smoother,
if we are getting a bit more of a chug.
One of them is, is we can go ahead
and look at some of our rocks up close.
And I'm gonna look at this material.
So I'm gonna click on the folder
where this material's located.
Oh, looks like that's my demo rock.
Let's go to a different one.
There we go.
Has the textures nested in here, because I'm making scans.
So I can go in here, and I can now,
if I wanted to, right-click and change these assets
to virtual texturing.
Now, you can also go in here and lower resolution,
if you needed to, by using a thing called
a bulk edit property matrix.
And this is a review again,
where you can actually open these up
and actually look at your resolution,
look at your compression settings,
and you can see we have a maximum texture size.
So I can cap that off if I needed to do so.
So that's actually really nice.
But what we wanna do is mainly switch this
to a virtual texture, and that's right here.
Now, if I converted this to a virtual texture,
it's gonna give me a, finding my conversion first,
it's gonna give me some options to be able to choose
this virtual texturing.
And what I mean by that, it's going to give me a list,
and you can see my list here.
It can say, hey, do you wanna do all of them,
or do you wanna just pick a certain ones to do?
And I can choose my resolution.
This is very important to consider,
especially when you're working with Nanite
and you're working with virtual shadows,
and say you have a big scene you need to manage,
you wanna make sure that you're activating this when needed.
I'm gonna hit cancel for now.
We're not gonna do that in this particular scenario,
just because it takes a bit of time,
and I don't want you guys
to get completely bored out of your head.
Now you'll notice in my scene, in my geometry,
if I click on some of these rock assets,
they are combined.
If I click on these two back in the distance,
they are now combined.
And the reason why that I merged those,
and you can see merge actors here that I can do that,
is because I wanted the draw calls to be light.
So I wanted my draw calls not to be heavy.
So if you have a lot of little pieces,
and they don't necessarily need to be moved around
all separately, and you know for sure
that they're gonna be a constant,
you can actually merge those as you need.
You can also go in here and convert these to Nanite.
So I have a rock up close.
You'll notice my resolution's not really high,
just so that you guys can download these scenes
without pulling your hair out.
But I can also go in here
and grab this piece of geometry at any time,
and it's a bit different compared to Unreal 5.0.
I can now go in here and go straight to Nanite.
So I can click on Nanite and make this a Nanite object.
Now again, the benefit, and I'm gonna make sure I do,
I'm gonna turn that off for a second here.
The benefit, first I wanna do is check this out.
Very important, make sure you do that.
The benefit of doing that
is gonna give me a higher shadow quality.
And I can bring in a higher resolution model.
So you can do that all through Bridge also
within Quixel Bridge.
When you export your geometry in your scene,
you can tell it to be a Nanite object.
So again, this is where I emphasize having a game plan,
knowing exactly what your visuals are gonna be.
So you wanna make sure before you get on the wall
that you consider these things ahead of time
so you don't necessarily bloat your scene unnecessarily.
So this has now become a Nanite object.
And I also wanna be able to click on this object
and I'm gonna type in Nanite.
And again, this is a review for some of you before,
but I'm gonna make sure I point these out.
And I'm gonna enable my Nanite support
and I wanna build my Nanite in my mesh.
Now, when you build that Nanite,
you'll see a little bit of like a shadow shift
in some cases on your object.
What's happening is you're letting Unreal know
that you're using Nanite information
on this particular object.
And you're not necessarily
going to be using your LODs now.
You're gonna be leaning more on your Nanite information.
And again, Nanite works as a review again,
repeating myself, I know,
the Nanite works like your virtual shadow maps
and like your virtual text train.
It only draws a high quality information that you need
according to where your camera's pointing direction.
That's what makes it so unique and so awesome.
All right, so let's talk a little bit
about our Lumen optimization for a moment.
So I'm gonna click on Lumen here.
And I should say my light in its Lumen mode.
And again, you wanna make sure your light is movable.
My light's completely movable in our scene.
We wanna make sure that in that,
we wanna double check on our settings for Lumen.
Now, we talked about this in previous classes,
when it comes to your project settings.
And you wanna go to rendering.
And in rendering, you wanna make sure
that you're set to Lumen
and that you are leaning on your ray tracing when available.
You'll see support hardware ray tracing
and also use hardware ray tracing when available.
I've kept things pretty simple.
And a lot of times you kinda want to,
when it comes to your volume,
you can change your surface catch to hit for reflections.
That could slow things down a bit.
So just be aware if you do that,
you gotta have kind of a beast of a machine
and a setup for your volume,
especially depending on your complexity.
And then you also see global tracing.
We could put detailed tracing, but also keep in mind,
this is also a GPU hog.
You can also do that through your post-process volume
after the fact as an override,
which is actually kind of handy.
So if I go to my outliner,
I'm gonna collapse my geometry folder.
And when we go to my post-process volume,
I can go in here and take a deeper look
at some of my settings.
We'll see that our reflections are set to Lumen.
This is gonna be handy in this particular water scenario.
And you'll see that we also have
our project defaults active.
So we can actually flip those at any time
if we needed to and go to the higher resolution ones,
which we talked about.
Now, if you were to use anything
like screen space information,
you also wanna make sure in your NDC that you overscan.
We're not using any screen space global illumination.
We're strictly using Lumen just because we can get
some nice updated information on the fly.
And what I mean by that,
is if I go in here and rotate my scene
and go ahead and switch to the volume, Kevin, thank you,
you'll see that it's now automatically updated
on our volume.
This is really awesome.
And I can't tell you how great this is
because before it was very chuggy to do this with Lumen.
And I can now change my time of day,
go ahead and leave that camera shot there,
change that angle.
So if the director wants the sunlight
coming from a different angle, he can.
That's like a really bright day in Tahiti there.
We can do that.
I'm changing this on the fly.
Oh, got a little stuck on my mouse there.
And there's the lighting change.
And we can also do that through a level snapshot.
I'll point you to it in level snapshot,
but I'm not gonna hold you there
because we do have a class on that
and talks about how to do it.
But that can give you a quick access to it
without having to rotate constantly.
Pretty awesome to be able to do that and get that working.
So let's go into Unreal Engine again,
and let's go and take a look here
at some of our options again with Lumen.
So let me go to my post-process volume.
Now you'll see Lumen global illumination.
There's a few more settings
that we didn't necessarily have before.
There's a max distance trace,
and I've kept that at 20,000.
Now that actually works pretty well.
But again, you can increase this as you need to,
but be very sparing with this.
Because overall what this does,
it controls the maximum distance that Lumen should trace.
So it's actually looking at how far
we need our accuracy to be.
And in the LED volume,
you don't necessarily have to go very far
in your environment.
You wanna keep things up close and working great.
So the default works pretty darn well.
There's also an advanced setting here.
You'll see that we have a final gather lighting speed.
In here, we have ours set to one.
This controls how much, again, Lumen,
don't you love Unreal?
Gives you a little cheat sheet here.
Again, final gather is allowed
to catch the lighting results to improve the performance.
But again, larger scales will chug things
if you're not careful.
There's a diffuse color boost you get,
a sky light leaking that you get here,
and a full skylight leaking distance here.
So overall, these are some of the improvements
that you have with Lumen.
And you'll see also reflections, like we talked about.
You can have high quality translucency reflections.
And we have water here, so we wanna keep that on.
And I could turn that off if I needed to,
if my water was pushed farther back,
and I didn't care if the light is passing through.
But these are all the things to consider
when you're working with Lumen,
and the accessibility that you get is pretty awesome.
You'll see here, take a snapshot.
We talked about this before.
So we can open level snapshot.
And you'll see that I have a couple already in my scene.
So if I select this one, I double click on it,
it'll say, hey, do you wanna restore that level snapshot?
And I can.
And your director is going to be a very happy person.
Because you can have multiple of these in here,
and is now very much optimized in Unreal,
allowing you to actually load quite a bit,
and be able to update those scenarios if needed
for particular shots or looks that need to be explored.
So I wanna backtrack just a bit,
and take a moment and take a look at Insights.
Now, the whole reason I brought that up earlier
is so that you could see that you could run Insights
via your switchboard.
You can run a command line and get it going.
But you can also, like mentioned before,
run it through an EXE on your desktop,
or even run it through here.
Now, believe it or not,
running Unreal Insights here is not too bad.
And the fact that it actually works like your EXE.
So it does it kind of independently.
The only thing in caveat you have to be concerned about
is sometimes when you're running,
you're analyzing your Unreal Insights,
it may be a little bit stubborn to stop the trace.
So you may find yourself trying to continually
get it to stop.
You'll see like there's a trace here that it's doing live
and I can open it because it's analyzing my scene.
But I can go in here too, and eventually it will.
So don't be afraid that it will fill up your hard drive.
It will actually start to go away.
And at any time you can go in here and find these traces
and you can delete them and stop them from production
or just clear out your hard drive.
You just need some space.
But we have an inventory of them in here.
We can connect to our,
again, you can see where you can connect
to your particular computer that you want.
In our case, it would just be us.
We can see we're connected.
So I can go ahead and run the trace on this
if we wanted to.
Now you'll notice this is open trace.
So again, all of your categories that you have,
like say I want to open this trace,
I can take a look at a previous trace that I did,
or I can just go back into my session here
and I can find, maybe I want to look at the live one.
It's in a live trace.
So we can start the trace.
And again, we've gone over this before in class,
how this actually works.
So you'll see it's still loading that trace there.
So let's go ahead and we can grab that live session
if we want to.
And we'll say open that trace and open it up.
And you'll notice we can actually do a comparable.
Here's like one trace compared to another trace.
You can do a live session trace
and see what a previous one looks like.
All of this is accessible to you.
And it's actually kind of nice to be able to do so.
So you can actually see, hey, where is this going?
So say we want to stop this trace.
Now this is where it can get a little bit weird
sometimes and again, it is in its early stages
and gets better and better.
So we'll go ahead and do a trace stop
and we'll see if it wanted to do that for us.
Looks like it's still going and we'll do a stop trace.
Do both commands here.
And this is kind of a little bit of my only big caveat
with this is getting it to do what you want
can be kind of a pain in the butt
when the fact that sometimes it will just keep going.
Most of the time if you just close the scene
you should be good to go, shutting out of all systems.
And we can also do a control alt delete
if it just gives you some trouble
and you really want to get that sucker to not run
and you'll see that it's running independently.
So if I really wanted to stop this trace
I can end that task.
I can end this task and I can end this task here.
And it does it independently.
You'll see right here is a good example
of how it does it independently.
So if it is stubborn, that's the one way you can do that.
That's my only thing, kind of a little bit of a hard ask
I'd like for that to change, but we're working on it.
So be patient with us.
It gets better and better.
And session front end is also an option
if you want to do that.
Less of a problem with the stopping
and doing what you want.
Now, if we do bring up in here,
Unreal Insights again, run that again,
pull this in here.
We don't need to run a new trace or anything.
You'll notice it'll start to continue where it left off
sometimes, which is a little bit, not so much.
You do have the option to delete these two,
but as a live one, you'll notice it's grayed out.
It won't necessarily go.
So that's again, some things to consider,
but you'll notice in here too, as we go in here
we analyze, let's actually open up
something a little smaller.
We'll do this one here.
That's not too big.
Open that trace.
You'll notice you can go in here
and click on any area of data.
And you can see my GPU thread, my game thread,
my RHI thread, and also my render threads.
You can analyze these and you can isolate GPU and CPU.
These are really helpful to work with
and things to consider.
You'll see we also have the counters
because really what we're looking for
is where our lag is at.
Where's our milliseconds being hit?
Where are things giving us trouble?
You can see our session here that we have set up,
give us a details where that session is,
where the U-trace is nested and living,
and you can have all this data ready to go.
Cool.
All right.
So again, let's actually kill that trace
so it doesn't continue.
It's using that data.
And since it's a separate function,
it's still maybe trying to get that information
to come out the door.
You can see that it's still loading up a little bit there
and it's running live.
So we can do just a real quick control, I'll delete.
Since my stop trace wasn't finding us just a little bit.
And again, you can try to run it.
Sometimes it's a little bit of a refresh issue.
Let's try to do a trace pause
and see if that'll take in this particular case.
And it did.
It looks like it paused for us.
Let me check the session.
Let me check the other log.
Nope, still going until it's like, ah, all right.
And then in that case, we'll just do control, I'll delete
and tell those two Unreal insights to end the task.
Don't continue where you left off.
There you go.
And when you close out of the engine
and when you reboot or close your computer,
it should kick that out.
And that information shouldn't be there
if it gives you a bit of trouble.
It doesn't always do this.
In another demo I did, it stopped, paused just fine.
Some of that might be a product of Zoom.
There is sometimes Zoom and refresh
that might give you a little bit of trouble.
So we see this here.
We see all of our stuff in place.
And what we wanna do here is now let's go
and take a look at fog and what we can do with fog.
We're gonna start off with this little small scene
and we're gonna move on to another scene
which has some really great also optimization samples.